[Musique]
pèse
480 8 tonnes
il pèse 4 188 tonnes si on prend
l'ensemble des baguettes qui sont
consommés à caen pour une seule année
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle de ça
et bien j'entends souvent mes proches et
mon entourage me dire que ils n'ont pas
d'impact et qu'ils ne peuvent rien faire
pour le changement climatique
eh bien je pense qu'on a visé juste avec
le thème un
visible alors non je parle pas du
changement climatique que ce soit les
catastrophes naturelles de ces dernières
années etats unis australie canada ou
même belgique et allemagne ou même ces
dernières semaines les changements de
température
clairement on sait pas besoin de moi
pour voir que le changement climatique
est une réalité
non moi je vous parle de nos gestes nos
actes ce que l'on fait tous les jours
notre consommation et l'impact que cela
alors oui
on a changé plein de choses dans notre
habitude regardez qui parmi vous
triste c'est poubelle je vois pas très
bien mais je pense que c'est comme à peu
près 84% des français
oui
qui éteint toujours la lumière en
sortant une pièce
vous voyez
on a changé pas mal de choses
qui parmi vous fais pipi sous la douche
on est souvent un peu plus timide
mais vous voyez on a changé plein de
choses et pourtant le changement
climatique est bien là
alors oui vous allez me dire ouais mais
nous on n'a pas d'impact regarde la
chine regarde les industriels ok c'est
vrai eux aussi ils ont un impact
mais cette remarque me gêne toujours un
petit peu je trouve ça bizarre de se
comparer à un pays ou à une entreprise
les ordres de grandeur sont pas les
mêmes
d'autant plus aujourd'hui dans une
économie mondialisée si compliqué de
blâmer un pays où une usine
je pense qu'on a tous chez nous un objet
qu'on affectionne particulièrement
et qui a été confectionnée avec amour en
chine
alors c'est compliqué de leur jeter la
faute
reprenons ce papier c'est pas juste 3 g
il a fallu le produire jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il n'a pas poussé dans un
arbre dans le fond du jardin notre
boulanger
on a eu besoin de voies d'eau et du zen
une parfois deux pour transformer
une fois qu'il est transformé eh bien
il faut le souk et ça consomme de
l'énergie et ça a un impact
ensuite on doit la mener seule grosse
chez un grossiste avec un transport ça
consomme de l'énergie et ç'a un impact
avant de l'amener chez notre boulanger
avec un nouveau transport qui consomment
de l'énergie aie qui a à nouveau un
impact
ça y'est pas de papiers et enfin cela tu
plonges et on va pouvoir acheter notre
baguette avec ce fameux papier
un papier pour une baguette pour une
journée
on rentre chez nous on mange à la
baguette et c'est pas fini c'est pas
parce qu'on jette notre poubelle et
quand on est tous très assidu de la
poubelle jaune qui ne se passe plus rien
après
non on sort notre poubelle jaune et un
camion va venir le chercher pour
l'emmener au centre de tri d'ailleurs si
on devait ramasser les 488 tonnes en une
seule fois on aurait besoin de 24
camions bennes
24 c'est énorme je vous laisse vous
imaginez les 24 camions passaient en bas
de chez vous pour amasser un papier
qu'on aura utilisé une fois pour une
baguette
ils arrivent au centre de tri
malheureusement on n'a pas de centre de
tri dans toutes les régions par exemple
on en a pas en normandie donc ces
camions parcourent des kilomètres pour
pouvoir trier ses déchets
quand on écrit on se rend compte qu'il
ya 20% de cette poubelle qui n'a rien à
y faire
alors je parle pas des plastiques qu'on
ne pourra pas recyclées non des produits
qui ont vraiment rien à y faire
des bouteilles des déchets ménagers la
literie de votre chat ça n'a rien à y
faire ça veut donc dire que il ya deux
camions sur dix qui sont partis faire
des centaines de kilomètres
pour rien
une fois triés
et bien à nouveau transport et on doit
la mener dans une usine pour le recycler
et enfin offrir une seconde vie à ce
papier
mais
c'est la même chose on n'est pas
vraiment équipés pour voir tous les
recycler et tout s'est transformé alors
une partie d'échec qui est enfoui une
partie qui est incinéré et une partie
qui est exporté
est encore en fait pas vraiment
m'avancer sur des chiffres ou sur cette
filière c'est tellement invisible on a
tellement peu de données que
je peux rien vous confirmer
et c'est ce moment le moment où je me
suis rendu compte que ce déchet
que il avait probablement film que
j'avais utilisé une seule fois qu'ils
avaient probablement finir dans le sol
ou
chez quelqu'un dans un autre pays que je
n'avais jamais vu dans son jardin
c'était plus possible pour moi et c'est
à ce moment là que j'ai décidé de
réduire mes déchets est passé au zéro
déchet parce que la solution n'est pas
d'arrêter de trier puisque finalement
dans la poubelle classique c'est 75 %
des déchets qui n'ont rien à y faire
alors oui ça n'a pas été évident de
passer au zéro déchet
et si je vous parle de ce papier c'est
pas pour rien moi c'est la première
chose que j'ai voulu enlever de mon
quotidien tous les jours j'allais
chercher ma baguette et je me rendais
compte que déjà arrivé chez moi j'avais
mangé la moitié
et que j'allais le jeter le soir même
ça m'a pris quatre jours
d'arrêter cette habitude
je voulais raconter
premier jour je suis allé à la
boulangerie j'ai commandé ma baguette
sur sortie et
j'avais toujours papier autour j'avais
complètement oublié ça faisait tellement
partie de moi de mes habitudes et de mon
quotidien que j'ai complètement oublié
alors le deuxième jour je m'en étais
tellement voulu que en retournant à la
boulangerie avec bien en tête qu'il
fallait vraiment que je reparte sans
papiers j'arrive devant la boulangère et
j'ai pas osé j'ai pas osé demander une
baguette sans papiers parce que j'avais
peur d'être jugé
j'avais peur de l'embêter
j'avais peur j'avais peur et du coup je
me serais mille excuses j'avais pas les
mains propres
j'avais pas de sachets il y avait du
monde bref tout y est passé
genre sortis de la boulangerie et
ma baguette avait toujours ce papier je
m'en suis voulu toute la journée
alors le troisième jour je suis arrivée
à la boulangerie j'ai pris mon courage à
deux mains et j'ai enfin osé demander
une baguette sans papiers donc savez
quoi la boulangère me l'a donnée elle
m'a remercié
alors je suis sorti j'étais là avec ma
baguette j'avoue je la tenais à deux
doigts parce que j'avais l'impression
qu'il était tout nu
mais j'étais tellement contente de moi
j'avais enfin réussi à commander une
baguette sans papiers
quatrième jour je rentre dans la
classique plongerait la boulangère me
regarde et me dit une baguette sans
papiers c'est ça ça y est c'est est
acquis
alors oui ce papier à l'échelle de la
journée de ma journée à mon échelle ça
représente vraiment pas grand chose mais
à l'échelle d'une ville et à l'échelle
d'une année ça représente
480 8 heures
et pour moi c'est ce qui m'a permis de
mettre le pied à l'étrier
c'est ce qui m'a permis de commencer
cette démarche et depuis je suis un
séparables avec ma demande je les ai
tous jours avec moi et j'ai toujours un
petit sac ou un tupperware avec moi au
cas où j'aurais besoin d'acheter quelque
chose
est bien évidemment on ne sera pas
parfait du jour au lendemain et on a
tous nos incohérences moi la première
des fois je prends ma voiture pour un
tout petit trajet sous prétexte que il
pleut ou que je n'ai pas le temps et je
m'en veux alors tous les jours quand je
fais quelque chose quand j'achète
quelque chose je me demande quel impact
ça et comment est ce que je peux faire
pour faire mieux comment est ce que je
peux changer m'améliorer et j'y mets
tout mon coeur parce que
dans quelques années je veux pouvoir
regarder un enfant dans les yeux et lui
dire on le savait alors on agit un peu
tard mais on nage parce qu'on avait les
armes et qu'on pouvait le faire merci
[Musique]